una contraofensiva celebrada por unos y
negada por otros el ejército ucraniano
anunció este lunes que sus maniobras
para recuperar terreno en la región de
gerson en el sur del país han sido
efectivas
hemos liberado unos 500 kilómetros
cuadrados y podemos ver que en la región
de gerson las localidades de viso cópil
ya vivir acá sookie stackhouse y miroli
o bizca hasta la fecha están liberadas y
se encuentran totalmente bajo la bandera
ucraniana
según los prorrusos las palabras de kiev
son falaces desde el kremlin sostienen
que las tropas ucranianas no han
recuperado ni un metro en persona además
apuntan a que la región sureña en estos
momentos no está ni siquiera bajo
amenaza
de región de gerson sigue y seguirá bajo
el control de las tropas de la
federación rusa with crisis que pidió
hace años que culpan y con gerson no hay
ningún retroceso en ninguna parte y
además no hay ningún apoderamiento de
bienes
mientras ucrania aseguró que su efectiva
contraofensiva les ha dejado un saldo de
cerca de 3.000 kilómetros reconquistados
en la región de jarquín también señalan
que el ejército enemigo lleva varios
días atacando infraestructura civil por
su parte desde moscú apuntan a que la
ofensiva se centra en objetivos
militares y que ya causaron bajas de 250
soldados y 20 unidades de equipo militar
por segundo día rusia está aterrorizando
jarquín destruyendo la electricidad y
otras infraestructuras clave en algunas
zonas no hay agua ni gas les aseguro que
los servicios municipales funcionan como
siempre todo se restablecerá podemos
reconstruir todo lo que los rusos han
destruido
el instituto para el estudio de la
guerra evaluó este lunes que ucrania ha
cambiado la marea a favor pero que la
actual contraofensiva está lejos de
poner fin a la guerra